hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in his essay
concrete approaches to investigating the
ontological mystery Gabriele Marcel
talks at one point about the inter
relation between the realm of the
problems or the problematical as opposed
to that of the mystery or mysterious and
the realm or world that is reduced to
you might say not quite a playground but
a field for techniques or if you prefer
another translation techniques so what
he's talking about here is a little bit
broader than just ways of doing
something like a set of dance moves or
something you might learn from a YouTube
tutorial he's discussing everything that
that fits into the scope of Technology
of disciplines of procedures algorithm
steps everything that can be you might
say cordoned off or compartmentalized
into a problem to be solved and there's
there's a very strong connection between
these things he expresses this very well
in pointing out that there's really four
aspects he doesn't name this this is me
denoting this for
but there's four aspects to the world of
the person and of the cultures that are
particularly focused just on problems in
lose sight of mystery and everything
else that goes along with that so this
is what he calls a broken world at
different points he tells us the world
of the problematical so what is the
world of the problematical the world in
which everything is looked at in terms
of problems problems are things that can
be formulated things that can be solved
or at least deferred if we can't solve
them right away we can say why it is
that we can't solve them a limit case of
this would be a mathematical problem you
know the old things that you had an
algebra class about the Train that's
headed off to Denver at 60 miles per
hour with such-and-such a distance and
another train is coming to meet it at 30
miles an hour where do they actually
meet that's a good example of a problem
other problems may have to do with you
know things that are a bit more
practical you know you look at your
hands you're like oh I've cut myself I
need to go and find the what thing to
clean it out and maybe some ointment to
put on it and a band-aid or you might be
you know say playing an instrument and
you you listen and the chord that you're
playing let's say it's a stringed
instrument doesn't sound right well
something must be out of tune let me
play the different strings and see which
of them or perhaps which two or three
are out of tune with each other maybe
you get yourself a pitch pipe blow it on
it and use all that that note is the
right note I need to you know tune this
a little bit differently what you're
doing there is a technique and you're
using that technique to solve a problem
so Marcel tells us the world of the
problematical the world in which
everything is viewed in terms of a
problem is the world of desire and of
fear which he says cannot be separated
from
one another why those two F activities
why not the world of pain and pleasure
why not the world of fear and hope he
has a long discussion about why he
thinks Spinoza was wrong in opposing
hope and fear and Spinoza isn't the only
person to do that by the way why desire
in fear because these are emotions that
everybody can relate to and they tie in
very closely with the realm of problems
and techniques as we'll see in just a
moment he says this is also the world of
the functional or functional izybelle
that he discusses at the very beginning
of his essay what is that well
everything is reduced down to functions
and a human being is understood in terms
of their vital their psychological their
social functions without their being
sort of a kernel of individuality that
escapes those functions in a meaningful
way because it's quite possible to have
individuality in a manner that's
completely functionalized great example
of this was Burger Kings advertising
campaign back when I was a teenager that
stress that you can have it your way
right we will take your orders and make
the the whopper however you like meaning
that they'll take the ingredients that
they have and if you don't want onions
on it you don't have to have onions but
you're not going to have anything that's
not in the panoply of the Burger King
repertoire of different things you can
put at it you can put onions put pickles
you can put ketchup mustard mayonnaise
you can put Tomatoes if you want to but
you're not going to get other things
that's just the way it works and it's
going to be done by somebody who has
sliced all these things up ahead of time
who has so much time to get your whopper
prepared everything has been funk
that's not real individuality desire and
fear are felt by individuals there's
nothing wrong with desire in fear but a
world that is primarily oriented in
terms of desires and fears is a world
that can be effectively
compartmentalized and commodity Kamata
sized and turned into a matter of
problems to be solved or techniques to
be applied if you think about what
advertising does most advertising is
really appealing to those two things
even if it appeals in some sense to hope
it's probably more appealing to fear for
example FOMO fear of missing out right I
hope that I'll get to go to the concert
why because I don't want to miss out on
anything that I see on the TV or hear in
some podcast that's going to be
happening see in social media social
media makes it possible to be even more
involved with this and social media
would be some of these techniques or
techniques that Marcel is talking about
so another aspect of this problematical
world as he says is that it's the world
where techniques of whatever kind
reigned supreme
so notice he's not saying it's a world
that's just of techniques but techniques
reigned supreme what does this mean
think about some examples
let's take dating for for example now
you could go and meet somebody if you
want to get involved with with you know
some romantic partner by meeting
somebody and an organization that you
belong to a lot of people meet people in
the workplace but you could also get on
a dating app right where you create a
profile and everyone creates profiles in
basically the same way sometimes with a
little bit of innovation and you know
funny stuff with the picture interesting
stuff and how they account for
themselves but it's really all the same
platform as a matter of fact you could
say well there's different dating
platforms out there well sure but they
all do
much the same thing they're all set up
in more or less the same way whether
there's some very complicated
personality test oriented one like
eHarmony or whether there's something
that that's oriented just showing you
who's in the area and giving you their
picture and allowing you to chat with
each other it's all mediated through
technology and it all ends up reducing
the interactions in a certain way you
might say well what wait a second what
if you go on a date with the person sure
now you're actually meeting face to face
which hopefully is the intention of it
right not just a date and avatar but
that could easily become something
that's dealt with just in terms of
functions sexual function for example or
a prestige function or any other thing
like that
and there's techniques I mean people
come up with books about how you're
supposed to pick up people who you're
attracted to
now I mean that's not to say that any of
this stuff actually works but what's
important here from ourselves
perspective is that techniques do reign
supreme they are what drives everything
else there are the things that dictate
how we approach things how we understand
things now all of these are
interconnected he tells us that there is
no technique that is not or that could
not be put directly at the service of a
given desire or a given fear and
conversely every desire and every fear
will tend to create techniques geared
towards its own ends every technique
serves or can serve through through
mission creep or however you want to put
it a whole host of desires and fears
every desire a person has will find
somebody who will create a technique at
probably a platform and act for that as
we used to joke around when apps were
becoming a big thing for dealing with
that that that matter
not everything is is susceptible to that
can you create an app to
make somebody feel loved they're making
robots right now that simulate that you
know they snuggle up with a person and
you know warm up and maybe say little
soothing things but it's not quite the
same thing as the satisfaction of that
desire unless a person's desires
eventually get replaced by desires for
that sort of stimulus likewise
fears so he also says that you know what
we've got here are these different
things connected up with each other
these are all part and parcel of a world
like that now there are consequences
I was almost jokingly thinking I'd say
there's problems that arise from this
world but they're not actually problems
as such they're meta problems so let's
just call them consequences one of the
consequences that Marcelle signals I
think something that many of us can
relate to because this is just as true
in our time as it is in his own he talks
about sensing the global bankruptcy of
techniques as a whole and feeling a
sense of despair as a result why he says
that we have not ceased believing in
techniques that is envisioning reality
as an ensemble of problems to be solved
but we notice that some of the things
that we frame as problems which Marcel
would say they're not really problems
they're really mysteries but we lose a
sense of how to frame those if we frame
them as problems we realize that
techniques are not are not going to help
us with them or if they do it'll be more
or less accidentally you know I'll give
you an example
what's the right thing to say to
somebody who's grieving you know you can
say I'm so sorry for your loss and
sometimes that helps and very often that
doesn't know if your goal is just like
satisfying a social requirement a social
function then you're off the hook but if
your goal was really to reach the other
person and help them with this effective
state of grief that they're in then
who knows there are no hard and fast
rules that govern this this is not
something that you'll be able to through
neuroscience or whatever other things
somebody comes up with you know develop
an app or program or algorithm that will
take care of things so this is a big
problem the global bankruptcy of
techniques he says is as clearly
discernible as our it's partial
successes to the question what can
humans accomplish we still reply humans
are capable of what their technical
abilities can accomplish but at the same
time we cannot we cannot but recognize
that technical achievements are unable
to save us from our selves so there is a
whole range of things that techniques
can't really get to they might be
helpful as apparatuses or as tools but
something has to be guiding orienting
directing that tool
another thing that Marcel signals is
what he calls being taken over by
techniques this might be understood you
know in my recourse to that old slogan
or motto to the person who has a Hammer
Every Problem looks like a nail
[Music]
what's going on in there what's what's
in the background the notion that
techniques can solve everything and a
over-reliance on them that makes us
subject to them he tells us these
technical achievements are not able to
save us from ourselves and even appear
as he says to conclude the most sinister
alliances with the enemy that each of us
carries within himself what does he mean
there are our worst tendencies the
things that we haven't dealt with
traumas perhaps temptations so he says
being taken over by techniques what does
this actually mean it means becoming
increasingly incapable of controlling
them and become becoming powerless to
God
one's own power we have freedom we we
misuse the freedom and give it away to
these techniques so let's take some
examples from social media and let's do
it on a base level and a meta level so
some people look to social media for
affirmation of who they are and what
they stand for and what kind of person
they are and it matters to them how many
followers they have how many people are
paying attention to what they're doing
even if perhaps the follower count isn't
really accurate because they've been
muted or something like that and it also
matters how many likes they get if it's
on Twitter I suppose if it's on Facebook
or Instagram re sharing is very
important as well all of this is giving
you signals about your value for other
people and if that's something that
really matters to you then you might
start checking all that very frequently
or you might start modifying your
behavior and your desires start to
circle around this more and more and
more and more and more you might on a
meta level find yourself unable to tear
yourself away from the computer screen
or from your phone for any sustained
period of time another great example of
this is the sort of loops that were able
to create within human beings
psychologists figured this out and
people very quickly business people
figured out how to monetize this with
video games
think about how candy crush took in so
many people getting them to spend so
much time essentially their to not just
play around but to look at
advertisements or perhaps to become one
of those whales who spends a lot on
in-app purchases these are examples of
being taken over by techniques we could
talk about dating apps again and the
unrealistic expectations that they raise
for people the the boredom and jaundiced
eye that they
they turned towards the people's just
swiping over and over and over again or
doing whatever else you have to do to
move on to the next person some people
actually get on to those with no
intention of ever contacting anyone and
just swipe and swipe and swipe it's a
way of killing time again being taken
over by your techniques so he says that
this control for this control of one's
own power which is the realization in
the realm of the active life of what
I've called second reflection or a
reflection of the second power can only
find its center or source of strength
within recollection these are things
that quit becoming available for the
person who is taken over by techniques
who sees the world in this way who
reduces the world in that way who buys
into that view of the world he also
talks about a sort of cosmic hubris that
again we have more examples of in our
own time because I technology has
extended our capacities he has a great
example of the weather he says some will
object saying that those most compute Li
completely imbued with belief and
techniques are forced to recognize there
are vast domains over which techniques
have no control what matters he says is
not this observation but the way that
the mind interprets it how do we make
sense of that what attitude do we take
towards it says we're forced to admit we
have no control over meteorological
conditions but the question is whether
or not we judge it desirable and just
that such control be given to us so the
more that one fits into this viewpoint
losing the sense of the ontological the
more the one who has lost it will see
his or her claims as limitless extending
to a sort of cosmic governance because
he or she will become less and less
capable of inquiring about the
credentials he or she has to exercise
such authority and when you think about
the way that for example tech people or
people enamored of tech who are you know
sort of dazzled by it
talk about how they are going to trance
form the world and they paint these
incredible pictures and you know you
start thinking about all the different
things that would have to happen in
order for that really to work and you
see that they're blazing right over that
why because they have a desire that that
extends to the whole world they want to
change it they want to make people
different they want to make society
different and there is a sort of
pridefulness at the center of it where
does that come from an over-reliance an
incapacity to see anything other than in
terms of problems to be solved functions
fear and desire and techniques what
happens in the end through all of this
that Marcel is particularly concerned
about is that people end up becoming
incapable at least at the moment they
could come out of it they become
incapable of imagining or entering and
remaining in or participating in
something that goes beyond the realm of
techniques and you see this sad
spectacle over and over and over again
parents who can only see the stats of
their kids and can't actually look at
their kids people in hospitals being
reduced down to vital signals and in
charts and what's what's happening and
being only given a certain amount of
time because that's all that this
hospital system has rationed out for
them for the greater good of everyone
right or at least the stock holders and
we could go on and on and on with
examples of this but Marcel thinks that
these are intimately interconnected and
they become a sort of brittle and yet
thick you could call it superficial
cover for anything ontological anything
with depth that would lie beneath
you